[Music]
in richmond south west london
people were cautious about relaxing the
rules for christmas
to give people the wrong signal they're
always fine it's okay and they suddenly
you know one day of the christmas we can
sacrifice relaxing the rules
isn't a bad idea but it sounds like
we're going to have to then pay for it
afterwards
people are i think are just tired of
being stuck at home
so you need to have some sort of
freedom again
some scientists are strongly opposed to
suspending lockdown rules at christmas
the idea that we will have christmas and
then lock down in january
to me makes absolutely no sense i think
we should focus on
individually tailored plans for people
to have christmas
and ensuring the maximum amount of
protection
to those who are vulnerable
rebel tory mps are threatening to vote
against the three-tier system
unless it's shown to save more lives
than it costs
while labour wants more financial
support for regions under strict
measures
we need clarity about what economic
support package will go alongside
different types of restrictions we can't
go back to the shambles
we had before this lockdown
the pm is desperate to give the public
some good news
after months of restrictions but
caught between his scientists and his
back benchers
there are no easy choices john craig sky
news